So yeah, as far as
[UNKNOWN]
go, one thing that, again, with the computer game, you can do, your, your final
goal is whatever is on the screen. It's just a pretty picture, basically. you
can do anything you want with materials or lighting and so on. how AutoCAD, can
you contrast and compare as far as materials and lighting and so on andwhat,
how does that work in that?
&gt;&gt; a lot of that varies on customer because there's still a lot of work that's
being done in 2D with lines and not necessarily a realistic view of, of what's
going on. But the precision is still required. We, we had one customer that use
to print out boat hole designs at full scale, and then use, use that to
actually build his boat holes.
&gt;&gt; [LAUGH].
&gt;&gt; [LAUGH]
So it really varies when, when you're dealing with somebody who is working more
in, in a 3D environment, then, again, there are different levels. Sometimes you
want just sort of conceptual look for your design that you are going to present
to a client to show them what it is you want to build. But then, at some point
you want to get a realistic fully rendered ray traced image, so we need to be
able to support that level also. So, it's really is a great variety of
visualizations that are required in the CAD product.